So let's continue our discussion of the fake
council culture war and the entire apparatus
that's been built around things like Dr. Seuss
and Mr. Potato Head in the midst of covid economic
crisis, inequality, lack of access to health
care, falling humiliatingly and woefully behind
on climate on. And I can give you the full list.
You know the list Dr. Seuss and Mr. Potato Head
are what we are hearing about in right wing media.
This is something that Lachlan Marky Markey,
I'm not sure I was pronounce wrote about
in Axios this morning. And that's a really
important aspect of this. The new grift
is outrage, profiteering. Now, in a sense,
outrage profiteering has been around forever. The
idea of if it bleeds, it leads is sort of a nod to
outrage, profiteering. We know that salacious
and controversial stories in general generate
better ratings than stories about waterfalls and
ginger snaps. I don't pretend this doesn't apply
to The David Pakman Show if my show was all about,
you know, random good news. A charity built ten
toilets in some country this week. We'd be out
of business by now. Like I completely recognize
that. What makes many shows compelling is you
point to problems, you point to injustices,
you propose solutions. But Lachlan Marki in Axios
outlines something that has really grown lately,
which is the grift of profiting off of fake
scandals and fabricated outrage where there
should really be no outrage. Now, Markey writes
about it in axios more in the context of political
fundraising and campaigning. This is something
I've talked about for a long time. If the country
is more and more in favor of gay marriage being
legal, of abortion being legal than at any other
point in history. And it is the country is as left
as it's ever been on those issues. Why do right
wing politicians keep talking about those issues?
Well, the reason is that those are issues
where if you are opposed to gay
marriage, if you're opposed to abortion,
you are often viscerally and emotionally opposed
and you are likely to donate lots of money to a
candidate that shares your view on those issues.
So even though the country keeps moving further
and further left, these remain great
fundraising issues for Republicans.
They profit from generating outrage, often fake
around things like, you know, Democrats want to
abort your kids even when they're three years old,
that type of thing. But not only do Republicans
line their pockets with this outrage, porn and
profiteering, right wing media does it as well.
Look at Fox News over the last 72 hours, dozens of
stories. I'm not exaggerating dozens of segments
about Dr. Seuss. And that's because the
outrage generated by the fake headlines
about Dr. Seuss being canceled and these being
the new book burnings, those headlines generate
way more outrage and thus interest and Twitter
shares and Facebook views of Fox News clips. Then
a story about Democrats passed H.R. one. Which,
by the way, was our lead story today on the show,
and likewise there are now so many so-called
independent right wing channels that also
profit from fake scandals that they are similarly
grifting around this outrage profiteering. Now,
I don't I don't want to start naming names. I
don't even want to give them publicity. Many in my
audience will know the grift fake outrage channels
that I'm talking about. But this is the new grift,
and we shouldn't expect it to go away for as long
as it's profitable. Now, should our goal be to
make it less profitable? Well, you know what? If
if we fix the problems we have in this country,
the outrage grifting will become less profitable.
And what I mean by that is when we look at how
fake stories spread, they spread because they are
weaponized and targeted to uninformed people who
don't know any better and lack media literacy
skills with which they would say that it would
be humiliating for me to share this.
Many people I went to high school with
don't seem to have this ability. You should
see what I'm seeing on my Facebook page.
But people, if they were more educated and better
equipped with media literacy skills, they would
never share lots of the stuff that catches fire
on social media because people would say this
is obviously fake. I'm not going to share it. So I
don't know that the goal, the primary goal is not
let's make outrage profiteering less profitable.
The goal should be let's fix education, let's
teach epistemology media literacy and give people
tools which will naturally make this sort of
outrage profiteering less profitable. It won't be
unprofitable. It will be profitable to some degree
because of the tendency toward
toward where people gravitate to
salacious and explosive stories, even if
they're fake. But we could definitely take the
wind out of it by better with better education,
teaching media literacy and equipping people with
the tools that they need to identify that
this is not something I want to be sharing.